thank you to brilliant for sponsoring
this video go to brilliant.org
simon clark to get better at solving
problems and learn more about the
natural world
[Music]
my most popular video on youtube is my
day in the life of an oxford physics
student
which was in movember and so
the most popular image of me on the
internet is me looking like
this wonderful for this video i thought
it might be interesting to do
basically an updated version of that
vlog a day in the life of being
well a science youtuber because that's
kind of what my job most
accurately is although it's not
everything my job is
it's currently about 10 am and a lot of
stuff has already happened but boring
stuff like
working out and eating breakfast while
my days now are quite different compared
to back then
funnily enough one of the things i am
going to be doing today is studying and
actually specifically studying
one of the textbooks that i studied in
my master's when i was making that video
a whole video is going to come out about
this next month
so i've got about half an hour to bone
up on this and then i have a zoom call
with my publisher
about the book that i wrote i wrote a
book in case you missed that one
there'll be a card up here yeah probably
there if you want to
learn about that one
speak to you next week yep see you next
week cheers ian
that's all right all right bye
so that was the first chat with my
editor at the publisher
uh post book announcement um and
basically the start of this next round
of edits
uh because the book's not finished yet
i've written it but now it's like
to use the word that ian likes using uh
crystallizing the the subject matter and
making it really
pop what we've looked at so far is
basically the beginning trimming
uh potential fat that's on the bone
there's not actually too much at the
beginning at all
it's more actually the like connective
tissue between the
the big ideas but um later on i'm sure
there's going to be a lot more
harsh edits but uh it's an hour and a
half actually more jesus like an hour
and three quarters
talking about this big monolithic
project it's a lot of work
yet to do if you are interested in the
process by the way of how this actually
works
i am going to do a video much closer to
the time of release in
january uh about how the process works
of actually writing a book because
it's certainly been interesting to me
because i've been living it hopefully be
interesting to you too
[Music]
the valerians want to continue trading
with the federation to the finest
crew in starfleet engaged
[Music]
after lunch it was time to do some admin
including reviewing this week's episode
of the wikicast which is the podcast i
do of my
old housemate dan and then a couple of
emails before going back to
studying some qft somewhat unusually for
one of my normal days i'm not actually
doing any editing or
writing today so i'm not writing a new
video but what i am doing
is coordinating some research on the
next science video which is going to be
a planets video and that's something
that involves myself and dr hannah
wakeford and in this case actually a
whole load of people from the discord
so this has been a slightly different
project to normal it's been really cool
to work with other people a lot of this
job you are working
by yourself i think it's one reason why
i like streaming on twitch so much and
also why i like having special guests in
the
room like jasmine because you are
basically just working by yourself a lot
of the time
and any chance to collaborate with
others is very welcome
isn't that right baby
do you like collaborating with me i'll
take that as i know
ow ow claus jasmine owen
something that you might notice is that
today compared to the day that i had
in the oxford physics student video is a
lot more fractured
there's a lot more stuff going on back
then there was a kind of
purity of purpose in you basically just
did one thing
studying all day yes there were a couple
of other things like
there was a society event in the evening
but pretty much like 80
of the time if not more was spent in a
library
studying and in a way i kind of miss
that purity of purpose but i do think
it's more interesting to have a variety
of tasks that you do
every day and sometimes my days are like
that sometimes like last week for
example
uh pretty much every day was spent all
day
editing producing and animating the cold
war video that i did
but more often than not days are like
today there's a mix of
stuff going on because when you are
making videos for a living
you can't just work on one video at a
time like you've seen today
studying for quantum field theory that's
for a video
obviously filming this that's for a
video we've got the pre-production
for the next planets video there's
all the stuff to do with planet factory
and claw that i'm going to be doing a
little bit later on as well
you know you're balancing several
different projects all at once
and sometimes it's nice to just be laser
focused on one thing
but i think really i prefer this method
of
splitting your time i don't know if
that's something that just happens when
you get older generally or if it is
this thing of being your own boss and
being you know being self-employed you
have to do this
a bit more qft studying and then i got
about an
hour of time in working on a claw
scratch that
it's way too nice of a days for me to be
trapped inside all day
and pixel girl has rightly decided to
drag me out for a quick walk
we really are lucky to be so close to
the countryside aren't we this is
definitely a lesson i've learned since
fourth year
it's really important to take even if
it's just half an hour
off to enjoy something like a sunny day
with your partner
because yeah you might be losing half an
hour's work but
being happier means that the work you do
for the rest of the day
it's not going to drag as much it's
going to be better for you mentally
and you're probably gonna get more work
done life is more than just work
it's worth taking the time out character
[Music]
growth
[Music]
it is quarter to eight and day's work is
kind of
done uh in terms of the objectives that
i wanted to secure today so
did about three or four hours of qft
notes
we did the meeting with the book started
the ball rolling on the next round of
edits
started another ball rolling with the
next planets video sort of moving that
to the next stage
and a whole lot of other sunday
objectives like going to the gym
and playing the piano and taking
medication and
you know all the little wins so you know
so far pretty good
after dinner pixel and i did a work
session together she was marking some
tests while i was working on claude the
pet python climate model
that i mentioned in the previous vlog
specifically i was trying to fix an
issue that we were having with advection
based on a solution that i found online
the lighting makes this look like we're
in a mafia film
it literally looks like we are planning
the demise of
the corleonesi yeah she does well that
didn't work
found out that uh trying to half-ass
doing a solution that i found online is
not the same as doing the full solution
so i think what i need to do is go away
and uh
tomorrow actually
move over all the velocity grids by half
a grid so and see if we can work on
doing staggered grids from the ground
up which is probably less work than i
think it's going to be
as long as it works i don't actually
care how much work it is but that is a
problem
for tomorrow simon today simon has
about half an hour before bed so i'm
going to do the washing up and
paint some water for those of you who
are interested today i was painting some
eradicators because i have just finished
off all of my hawaiian orc boys
once i finished off these primaries i
can then move on to my demo character
what the oh no oh it's happened again
pixel girl pixel girl it's happened
again jasmine i love you but not now
the graphics have glitched again pixel
go we're stuck in minecraft
i can fix this i just need to i need to
think um
right okay let me sit in my computer now
this is a pretty difficult problem
if only there was a website that
specialized in teaching me how to solve
difficult problems
oh wait brilliant critical thinking
and problem solving are absolutely
essential skills to have as anyone who
has been trapped in minecraft graphics
will tell you
brilliant is a website and app that
allows you to train your problem-solving
skills and learn more about the world
around you by solving problems with
content available at every level from
introductory maths to graduate level
topics like quantum computing
there is guaranteed to be something in
brilliance courses that will interest
you whether you'd like to spend a few
minutes a day on your phone not
scrolling through reddit but instead
rediscovering chemistry
or supporting your learning in the
classroom with fun interactive
challenges
brilliant is the ideal way to improve
your knowledge of maths and science
and of course improve your
problem-solving skills because the best
way to learn
and the foundation that brilliant is
based on is to learn by doing and by
solving carefully curated practice
problems
you can go to brilliant.org simon clark
to get access to brilliance courses for
yourself
or gift access to someone as a
thoughtful present and if you're one of
the first 200 people to sign up you'll
get a sweet 20
off a premium annual subscription thanks
to brilliant for sponsoring this video
and for reminding me how to get out of
this mess
of course if i just hit this switch here
everything should go back to normal
that's why i keep it there
oh that was easy thank you so much for
watching this
experimental is experimental the right
word vlog
let me know what you thought of this
kind of blended style uh i'd
kind of like to get weird with these
vlogs wherever i can so yeah give me
let me know what you thought in the
comments thank you again so much for
watching
bam check out here for some previous
examples of
my vlogging and if you really like this
then you can subscribe thanks again i'll
see you in the next one
you